Part D find the average rate of change
of F on the interval from X is greater
than or equal negative four is less than
or equal to X which is less than or
equal to three so really the interval
that they've depicted right over here
and then they say there's no point C
between in that interval for which F
prime of C is equal to the average rate
of change explain why the statement does
not contradict the mean value theorem
fascinating all right let's do this
first part first the average rate of
change of F on the interval sounds like
a very fancy thing but the average rate
of change on the interval is really just
the slope of the line that connects the
endpoints of the interval so these are
this right over here those are the
endpoints and let's figure out the slope
of that line so going we going from this
point to that point our change in X we
just in a color that you're likely to
see our change in x over here our change
in X change in X is equal to seven and
you could get that by taking three minus
negative four you can literally discount
one two three four five six seven that's
our change in X and our change in Y when
we when we run over seven when we go
seven to the right our change in Y our
change in Y is equal to negative two we
went from negative 1 to negative three
is equal to negative two so slope slope
which is change in Y over change in X
rise over run is equal to 7 over
negative 2 or oh actually let me know I
the other way around change in Y is
negative two over seven so negative two
sevens and that's all it is now you
could you could kind of think of it in
kind of a more fancy sense but you're
gonna get the exact same answer if you
said oh well look you know the average
their average rate of change of F on the
interval well the rate of change of f is
f prime F prime of X that is the rate of
change of F at any point X and so if you
want to find the average value of this
over the interval you would integrate it
from our starting point from negative 4
to 3 DX and then you would divide it by
your change in X
so then you would divide it by you would
have it over 1 over 7 over 1 over 7 but
then this this part right over here is
just going to be the same thing as F of
3 minus F of 4 and then this over here
you have a 7 in the denominator so this
is really just your change in X this is
your change in X which is which it was
by definition or how we how we actually
set up this average right over here and
this over here is really just your
change in Y so it really is just the
slope between the endpoints so we did
the first part our average rate of
change of F on the interval is negative
2/7 and then let's think about the
second part they say there's no point C
in that interval for which F prime of C
is equal to the average rate of change
explain why the statement does not
contradict the mean value theorem so the
mean value theorem just is a little bit
of a review as a little bit of review it
says that if we have some type of an
interval if you have an interval so let
me draw some axes right over here if you
have an interval let me draw an interval
like this and over that interval you
have a differentiable function you have
a differentiable function so maybe my
function looks like this it says at
least there's at least one point C on
that interval where the derivative at
that point C is equal to the average
rate of change so the way I've drawn it
right over here the average rate of
change of this function I'll do it in
magenta is this right over here and the
mean value theorem says is that if this
is differentiable there's at least one
point C in this interval where I have
the same slope where the tangent line
has the same slope where the derivative
is the same as the slope as that average
slope and you can see here it was
probably right over here you have one of
those points and actually we probably
have multiple of them we probably have
another point right over here that's
like that and then another point there
that's like that and if you think about
it it's kind of it's kind of intuitive
that at some point you know here where
we obviously have a larger slope and
over here we have a smaller slope and
since our since it's differentiable our
derivative is continuous so at some
point at some point the slope has to get
to exactly what the average slope is
now let's think about our little
conundrum with this question right over
here why is there not a Point C for
which F prime of C is equal to the
average rate of change and you can even
verify that for yourself because from
negative 4 to 0 our slope is positive we
have a positive slope here and then the
slope just jumps down to negative 2 it
just jumps down to negative 2 which is a
much more negative slope than this so it
never goes to negative 2/7 and the
reason is is that this is not a
differentiable function at X is equal to
0 it is not differentiable at x equals 0
our slope jumps here and because it's
not differentiable the mean value
theorem doesn't apply now you can
imagine if this was differentiable if
this did have a continuous derivative
then you would find a point so if this
looks something like this instead I'll
continued over here if it looks
something like this instead where it was
it had a continuous derivative then
there would be a point where the slope
was the same as the average slope maybe
it would have been right over there so
it's really because it's really because
f is not differentiable over the entire
interval it does not have a continuous
derivative the derivative jumps from a
from a positive value approaching 0 here
and it just jumps straight down to
negative 2 right over here it doesn't go
continuously through all the values in
between